Now, imagine a city that's growing by half a million people in a month.
This is Second Life.
Not a real place but a virtual online world...
...where participants lead fantasy lives.
In total, one and a half million people have created...
...fictional versions of themselves here.
That's enough people to fill Birmingham and Edinburgh.
And here is where fiction meets reality: they're spending real money.
From Second Life, Rory Cellan-Jones reports.
Fly with me into a whole new world.
This rather strange-looking fellow is my avatar, my virtual me in Second Life.
Let's drop in on one of the residents.
Andy spends a lot of time in this world which the residents build for themselves.
Here's what he looks like in real life, where he is a college lecturer.
At first, it's difficult to see the point of Second Life,...
...but Andy says there's an awful lot you can do.
It's an escape for creativity, for exploration, for building friendships there.
They're pushing the boundaries of possibilities, really.
A little bit, yes.
If you can imagine it, you can do it in Second Life, and that's the fun.
Residents pay real money to buy land and can earn cash by selling virtual goods.
Justin here has built a whole business in this world.
His firm in London's East End designs virtual offices and equipment for companies...
...now rushing to establish a presence in Second Life.
People are in there, they're making real livings by buying and selling virtual land...
...and creating product for people...
...so they can adorn their own avatars and clothing or performing services.
For instance, there's wedding planners in there.
There's people who actually do live performance of music in there.